in that clip of Catherine the Great she
utters one of my favorite lines that
works all the time I say it all the time
I love saying I'll be the judge of that
everything like when the waiter says um
you know walk this way I'll be the judge
and there was a lot of those I think it
said it earlier today to someone but I
always loved to say um thanks for the
warning you know these are lines that I
tell the kids on our show if you don't
know what to say at least have 10 things
you could say like for small talk you
can have a list of 10 things to say that
work in every situation my favorite my
all-time favorite one is is is here it's
coming it's it is yeah
you will end up saying it tonight we'll
say here it is I got it I don't see how
they asked me a question ask me any
question okay so you grew up in
Louisiana I don't see how that's any of
your business
[Applause]
oh I have to save you the person I'm
just kidding because they no one ever
expects it so you we kiss oh the
takeaway here I don't see how that's any
of your business I'll be the judge of
that and what was my other one I said it
I have a short memory thanks for the
warning warning I'm Lucille Ball do
stuff one that actually was having
dinner parties up there and somebody
went to the loo when they came back in
you go tell her to her face
[Applause]
[Music]
you can finish up when your next go yeah
Oh
[Music]
you